welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the tv
trailer for marvel's doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness a tv spot that
i have mentioned in other videos but now
that we have a full high quality version
of it literally every frame of this is
filled with new visual clues that we
must discuss this time without me
ruining a super bowl party by spitting
out a mouthful of walk to scream
zombie warmed off from wolverine
sightings to wundergore mountain i'm
gonna break it all down let's go
what do you know about the multiverse
[Music]
[Applause]
we should tell him the truth
careful stephen
this path exacts a heavy toll
holy cothon they straight up cut a
different trailer with almost all
different shots than the one released
online so let's go through it the first
shot shows doctor strange christine
palmer in american chavez right before
strange opens that hatch to the ruins of
what i assume to be the utopian parallel
the home dimension of america chavez but
here you can more clearly see that
christine is wearing the pale blue
wardrobe that she wears under her white
lab coat while working in the illuminati
detention sector so this may be after
strange escapes with her and that
multiversal detainee america chavez but
they're coming from a basement that i at
first thought could have been the
sanctum sanctorum undercroft but the
overhead lights are different than in
spiderman no way home so instead this
looks like a kind of furniture warehouse
or depot where wooden bed frames and
cribs are stored maybe the multiversal
space where all those alternate cribs
and beds and couches and chairs from
wanda's west view house each time the
furniture got redecorated this could be
the backstage where they were stored
before she conjured them up into her hex
puppet show but the big detail here is
the fact that strange is using the eye
of agamotto opening it with the same
hand gesture that he used when he opened
it in the 2016 film except then he
crossed his arms to unwind the metallic
pieces to reveal the time stone's green
glow from within now he widens its arms
to unlock it to reveal a golden glow
that seems to be opening this hatch
maybe a backup more analog version of
using sling ring technology to open
portals through realities because
otherwise we don't see sling ring
portals in any of this footage we have
been wondering since no way home why
strange still wears the eye of agamotto
if the time stone was atomized in
endgame and since the necklace itself
was destroyed during strangest battle
with thanos and infinity war this might
give us the answer beyond housing an
infinity stone that allows time
manipulation this eye vagamoto contains
other kinds of magic that allows for
manipulation of the material world
perhaps bypassing other magical barriers
like some anti-sling ring portal spell
then we get another quick shot of
defender strange his striped hair tied
back mid fight against that ribbon-based
monster in the utopian parallel part of
a sequence where he may be rescuing
america chavez here you can see more of
the entity's ribbony anatomy and how
each strand is actually marked with
glowing runes many of which match the
general shape of the eye of agamotto i
still like this idea of this creature
being siturak since his body looks
somewhat like the glowing crimson bands
of cedar act the strange used on thanos
and infinity war but it could also be
some other mystic being from strange's
history like one of the entities strange
supreme absorbed in what if episode four
because later in this strange releases
serpentine dragons like the one strange
absorbed in that episode then we see the
sorcerers of comartage mounting their
defenses with eldritch shields and rows
of archers i like this overhead shot
giving us the full spatial geography of
the compound you can see that tree in
the central courtyard that's the same
tree that strange walked past in the
2016 film during his training in
kamatage and then on the upper mezzanine
level in the center of that battalion a
bonfire is burning making me wonder if
this is a kind of mystical torch lit as
a beacon for other sorcerers to come
defend the home base like the warning
beacons of gondor and lord of the rings
then a shot of scarlet witch wand a trap
surrounded by shards of mirror glass
this could be an attempt by strange or
wong or mordo to trap her in the mirror
dimension during a fight like strange
was trapped in the mirror dimension the
first time he used the ivagimoto time
stone or could be something like the
crystallic prison that strange and the
watcher used and what if but those
spiked shards actually look more like
the tortuous spell used by ebony ma on
strange infinity war the tips of wanda's
fingers here are black and even further
down on her fingers than when we saw her
in her seance in the other footage
meaning she may be further along in her
descent and behind her is a glowing
orange ring that looks like it is part
of the flooring of the camarata
courtyard meaning this could be part of
that sequence then mordo raises a sword
to strange in that same room as the
illuminati panel with the chairs on the
dais and you can see that there is
actually an empty space between the two
sets of three chairs and if we assume
that that spot is for charles xavier's
wheelchair or his hover chair that would
mean a seven-member illuminati and this
shot of mordo is actually briefly
eliminated by the flash of an explosion
so he may be raising his sword to
release strange to free him so that he
can help the illuminati against an
external threat from wanda then a low
angle shows america chavez directly
beneath gargantos showing us some
close-ups of his slimy tentacles in
toothed orifices this may be how america
eventually defeats him by kicking a star
portal into his belly there's an
interesting match cut from strange in
the alternate version of the sanctum
with a darkhold to christine palmer
walking down the aisle also with a
circular window framed directly behind
her head and then our clearest shot of
defender strange the moment he saves
america chavez in the foreground from
the ribbon monster in the background
this strange with the stripes in his
hair is the same one who later gets
zombified which might have been
something he did to himself as a kind of
self-sacrifice but here he uses a
three-dimensional version of eldritch
magic surrounding his fist which i
presume is a more powerful upgrade of
the normally flat discs of eldritch
magic that strange has normally used
then as strange faces the illuminati
panel the back of charles xavier's head
slides forward in the foreground that
smooth motion indicating that he may be
sitting in a hover chair as he did in
the revised timeline at the end of days
of future pass and of course in the 90s
animated series which is coming back as
x-men 97 to disney plus and this charles
may be a live-action version of that
character now it's not good to get
something intended for someone else
whether it's a restaurant order or a
medical diagnosis so you want to get the
thing intended for you well thanks to
helix you can get the mattress made for
you helix sleep makes premium mattresses
and bedding customized to fit your needs
and shipped right to your door helix has
a sleep quiz that matches your unique
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you i took the quiz
and i got matched with a dusk luxe helix
mattress because i wanted a medium firm
mattress with lumbar support that sleeps
cool i've had it for over a year i still
love it i've even moved with it it's as
good as new helix delivers your mattress
right to your door for free it comes
rolled up in a surprisingly small box
and is super easy to set up yourself
helix has a 100 night sleep trial so you
can get more than three months to make
sure you love it if you don't they will
pick it up for you and you will get a
full refund but you're gonna love this
mattress i love my helix and i think you
would too if you're looking for a new
bed check out helix you can click the
link below or go to helixsleep.com
rockstars and get up to 200 off your
helix mattress then christine palmer in
her lab coat as other illuminati
scientists flee through the lobby region
of the illuminati hq that's shot in the
british museum in london as ultron
sentries charge forward past them and
america chavez watches from inside a
container cell and in the background you
can see purple colored monitors
displaying something and yellow
emergency lights flashing all over this
room so part of the illuminati's mission
must be to detain multiversal fugitives
and this alternate reality christine
palmer works for that sector i've
speculated that among these prisoners
could be wanda's children billy and
tommy and that's why she's breaking into
this place those purple screens might be
showing a multiversal version of cerebro
that this charles xavier constructed to
locate other beans throughout the
multiverse but i want to dig into that
in another video and we gotta assume
wanda is what they're fleeing here from
that other gnarly shot of the bloody
face which also had these interesting
black stains on her top those stains
could actually be from the ultron
centuries that she slayed releasing an
oily discharge like their blood like
when she ripped ultron's robot heart
from his chest in age of ultron then a
shot of wanda whipping her head around
mid-fight in this setting with a ringed
wall pattern behind her we actually saw
america chavez fighting in this temple
in the online version of the trailer
those wall markings look a lot like the
page for the scarlet witch in the dark
hold and in that shot america leaps off
an altar that on the sides shows a
circle with a horned animal in the
center maybe the same baphometic skull
on the wall of agatha's basement so i'll
explain where i think this is at the end
of the video gonna make you stick around
then this awesome shot that many of us
called robbie rwanda but despite her
zombie-esque appearance much like the
rotting defender strange i don't think
this is exactly zombie wanda from what
if i really just think her scary haggard
appearance and glowing red eyes is just
this incarnation of wanda's evil
identity using red chaos magic to open a
portal from one place to another in this
case it looks like she's arriving from
an industrial setting something that
looks a lot like the old hydra lab where
she and pietro were experimented on and
portland into an entirely new setting
that has display cases like either one
of the sanctums or the british museum
home of the illuminati i like how her
chaos magic creates a snakey sinister
invasive quality compared to the sparkle
portals or the tba time doors that we're
used to seeing by the way yeah we should
just take a second to note that we never
in any of this footage see any of the
standard mcu sorcerer sling ring sparkle
portals instead every portal is one kind
of practical door opening into a new
setting kind of like the adjustment
bureau or the back doors of the matrix
sequels or willy wonka's magic door just
makes me think that one of these
governing authorities like the
illuminati might have dictated a
disabling of sling ring portals after
doctor strange's little buddies misused
them in the past doing this as a kind of
way to limit the movement of multiversal
fugitives forcing strange to use his
ivagamoto as a kind of hack to unlock
all locked doors and teleport into new
places then a close-up of zombified
defender strange again you can tell by
the hair stripes same guy his face in
his hand now rotting now the wounds on
his hands actually look a lot like when
they were broken after his car accident
and i may be reaching here i always got
to do at least once per video but in
addition to his cheek rotting away
across his face are three slashes like
ones that would be caused by a certain
famous set of adamantium claws you gotta
imagine if wolverine came across this
creeper on a mountain he would go for
the head but ultimately i think
strange's rotting state here is a result
of these smoky demonic entities that he
is struggling with in this moment
because the way his hand fans open
suddenly as those wisps snake around his
fingers make it seem like those other
spirits are inhabiting this flesh and
eating away it and as this strange poses
with his arms fanned out behind him in
the vinyl shot it is worth noting that
these dark skeletons are emerging from a
rift in reality itself a torn curtain
effect similar to reality splitting open
in spider-man no way home so these
things could be coming from a shadow
realm something like the mcu's version
of hell but this whole mountain where is
this my first thought of this
mountaintop was everest in the himalayas
where the ancient one stranded strange
in the 2016 film but you notice across
that range is another structure and that
could be the scarlet witch darkhold
temple that we saw earlier the shot with
wanda and the shot of america chavez on
that altar and that could make this
mountain wundergore mountain a critical
place for marvel lore where the demonic
entity cathan wrote the darkhold and
catholic was later entombed in this
mountain leading to the modern era where
herbert windham the high evolutionary
experimented on his new men and oversaw
the birth of wanda maximov and pietro
maximoff from a woman named magda this
point c'thun imbued his spirit into baby
wanda to mark her as the future scarlet
witch which could be why in one division
this same symbolism shows up in the dark
holes and foretold that prophesized
figure being wanda maximoff one division
might have even referenced this whole
backstory with that bova milk easter egg
bova being the high evolutionary
experiment who nursed wanda and pietro
when they were on this mountain in this
run of the comics so yes folks it looks
like all kinds of easter eggs i spotted
in one division are suddenly looking a
lot less reachy so we'll see who gets
the last laugh
oh no i didn't mean for that to be you
not to you sire no follow me on
instagram and twitter at yay voss follow
new rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you